aujourd'hui une vidéo pour vous aider
pour acheter faire des achats sur
internet sans avoir problème sans
risquer de se faire à bord se faire
arnaquer je me permets une fi nit
qu'elle est avec vous consoler dans les
couilles sur les 96 me tais absolue on
est vraiment d'entre nous donc ça c'est
vachement cool ce avait acheté sur
internet c'est pas toujours évident
alors soit vous avez des sites sur
lesquels vous avez l'habitude d'acheter
ou quelqu'un vous êtes tranquille vous
pouvez acheter là que vous savez que ça
marche
vous connaissez le process vous
connaissez l'entreprise il n'y a pas de
souci c'est une boîte identifié c'est
très bien sauf que vous voulez acheter
un produit bien voulu trop pas forcément
son site vous avez l'habitude d'aller ou
alors vous voulez voir un petit peu
ailleurs ce qui se passe parce que ça
vous semble mieux pourquoi pas mais il
faut connaître je dirais les rouages
savoir comment marche un peu le
e-commerce pour éviter de se faire
arnaquer pour éviter d'avoir des
déconvenues et croyez-moi ça n'arrive
pas qu'aux autres je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui pas moins de huit astuces
pour vous aider à y voir plus clair sur
vos achats sur internet
évitez vous faire arnaquer mais grâce à
ça vous allez pouvoir acheter en toute
confiance sans prendre de risques le
premier point c'est comparer par exemple
vous voulez acheter un nouveau smart de
l'ordinateur voulait acheter une robe
vous l'achetez ce que vous voulez
d'ailleurs c'est en ligne vous pouvez
l'acheter il faut aller comparer à les
voir sur plein de sites ce qui se passe
attention quand même aux tarifs qui
peuvent paraître beaucoup trop
avantageux beaucoup trop bas il
d'ailleurs d'autres vérifications à
faire mais ça je vous donne dans les
points suivants le point numéro deux
c'est de vérifier le vendeur savoir à
qui vous avez à faire est ce que c'est
un site marchand est ce que c'est la
marketplace par lé biais d'un site
marchand parce que oui pas y aller je
vous prends quelques citoyens que ce
soit nakk darty que ce soit cdiscount
que ce soit en azote
tous ces sites la vente par semaine et
vendre leurs propres produites mais il
ya aussi une marketplace est à dire
d'autres vendeurs qui va venir vendre
ces sites là et quand vous allez acheter
vous n'allez pas acheter directement un
smack darty cdiscount ou amazon vous
allez acheter directement aux vendeurs
sur la marketplace et c'est lui-même qui
va gérer son propre cerveau derrière
donc c'est très important de pouvoir
identifier qui vous vend à qui vous
acheter et qu'est ce qui va se passer
derrière au niveau de la vente est
également au niveau du service après
vente pour identifier c'est très simple
lorsque vous êtes sur le site c'est
marqué par qui est vendu le produit qui
va vous l'expédier savoir si c'est un
site que vous connaissez que vous êtes
rassurés ou alors est-ce que c'est un
marchand externe par le biais de la
marketplace on dit il faut vérifier les
avis assez important pas la vie sur le
produit mais la vie sur le marchand si
vous êtes convaincu du produit que vous
voulez acheter
surtout que le marchand montre patte
blanche donc pour ça vous allez
plusieurs systèmes vous avez les avis
existant directement sur les sites
notamment sur amazon vous allez avoir la
vie sur le vendeur une fois que
quelqu'un à acheter il peut laisser un
avis alors souvent l'avis concerne le
produit mais il concerne également le
vendeur à l'expérience de vente et
notamment dites vous bien que les
personnes qui sont mécontentes c'est
celle qui laisse le plus d'avis
contraire ment personnes satisfaites car
est le général on laisse beaucoup moins
il y a également des avis qui sont
certifiés des avis vérifier notamment
je prends l'exemple d'une entreprise
française qui s'appelle avis vérifier
qui va elle mettre des avis sur le site
marchand c'est à vila ne peuvent pas
être modifiées par le vendeur il peut
pas demander à les supprimer ils sont là
ils sont là donc les avis sont certifiés
sont vérifiés au moins c'est rassurant
si vous arrivez sur un site marchand que
vous ne connaissez pas et qui vous
paraît intéressant vous voulez savoir
qui est cette entreprise ce que je vous
conseille dans un premier temps c'est
d'aller voir les mentions légales vous
allez voir qui est l'entreprise
ou est ce qu elle est immatriculée on va
reprendre le centre de la france et bien
vous allez avoir un numéro de siret vous
allez connaître le nom du directeur de
la publication du site vous allez
connaître le siège social donc avoir
toutes ces informations là avec ces
informations-là pouvez venir les
vérifier notamment france vous allez sur
infogreffe point fr dansant societe.com
vous aurez calais la boîte vous aurez
des renseignements au dessus et au moins
vous saurez si une société qui a pignon
sur rue et qui est toujours existantes
si vous ne trouvez pas ça forcément vous
vous aussi vérifier le site en lui-même
vous cherchez worries w h aussi est ce
qu a fait ça dans votre temps de
recherche
ça permettra de savoir à qui appartient
ce nom de domaine vous copier coller le
nom de domaine www.truvada.com au point
fr vous connaissez vous le mettez et
vous allez voir à qui appartient ce site
où est ce qu'il est déposée en france à
l'étranger et au moins vous en saurez
plus que je vous conseille également
c'est de lire les conditions générales
de vente les conditions générales
d'utilisation puisque une vente c'est un
contrat pour vérifier de telle manière
vous allez acheter et voir tout est bien
aux règles et puis méfiez vous des sites
qui sont pas très clair pour moi quand
il ya un truc louche c'est qu'il ya un
loup c'est un principe que j'applique à
tous et je l'appliqué également l'absolu
c'est à dire si vous allez sur un site
qui vous paraît bien les produits seront
là les tarifs sont super cool mais elle
est toutefois un peu mal traduit des
caractères un peu bizarre il se peut que
ce soit un site qui propose de la
contrefaçon
méfiez-vous une fois de plus se regarder
s'il ya des mentions légales si c'est le
cas regardez où l entreprise au regard
des acquis et le site vérifier fait des
contrôles croisé entre les mentions
légales entre le wiz et vous saurez
exactement qui vous avez affaire
ensuite quand vous allez faire votre
achat est ce que vous allez acheter un
produit
neuf ou un produit d'occasion si c'est
un produit que vous avez vérifié que
vous avez contrôle et que vous savez où
vous achetez en règle générale n'y a pas
trop de soucis tisser un produit
d'occasion
il faut vraiment différencier deux types
de vendeurs le vendeur particulier c'est
à dire vous et moi qui vend son produit
qu'il vend un autre et le vendeur
professionnel qui vont en produits
d'occasion qui vend souvent produits
reconditionnés faut vraiment
différencier les deux alors sur l'achat
du particulier à particulier faut
vraiment faire extrêmement attention
pour moi ne jamais envoyer d'argent tant
que vous n'avez pas le produit sous les
yeux que je privilégierai quand même
c'est de pouvoir rencontrer la personne
voit le produit le tester et l'allumé
voor simard et une fois que tout est ok
vous pouvez payer comme ce moment où
vous êtes tranquille si maintenant vous
avez à faire un professionnel qui vous
vend un produit reconditionnés ce qui
est important c'est de voir
effectivement qui est le vendeur et
qu'est-ce qu'il va vous proposer comme
garanties derrière il ya différents
sites qui existent je peux prendre
l'exemple de riz commerce qui vous
propose un an garanties sur des produits
regarder vraiment qui vous avez affaire
de quelle manière dont vous traitez de
caisse qui vont vous proposer
derrière comme service s'il ya un souci
et n'oublie pas tout ce que vous achetez
un professionnel en tout cas si vous
l'achetez en france la loi vous protège
vous avez 14 jours pour expédier le
produit si vous n'êtes pas satisfait
vous avez trouvé un produit qui vous
plaît vous avez trouvé le site qu'il
vous semble en tout cas correct le
produit vous correspond vous êtes
satisfait et vous dites ok maintenant
c'est l'heure de passer à la caisse pour
vraiment vérifié le moyen de paiement
d'une façon un petit peu classique vous
êtes des moyens de paiement par carte
bleue par internet c'est bien souvent ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on fait le plus
vérifiez toujours que dans l'url dans
l'adresse internet vous avez https le s
est extrêmement important ça veut dire
que c'est une connexion sécurisée ça
c'est la base de la base de la base de
la base surtout sur un site de
e-commerce
mais à côté de ça il ya un autre plan il
faut vérifier c'est une femme vous aurez
cliqué et qu'on vous demande de rentrer
vos coordonnées bancaires sur quel s'il
vous avait été redirigés est ce que vous
êtes toujours sur le site du commerçant
à ce moment là est ce qu'il y à un
module qui vient vous sécurisez ça oui
ou non au ce que vous rentrez votre
numéro de carte bleue sur un formulaire
rappelons dans quelqu'un faut quand même
se méfier si vous êtes redirigé sur un
site ça peut être complètement
transparent vous rendez pas compte vous
le verrez dans votre barre d'adressé
https deux points cela slash www.la vous
allez pouvoir identifier le nom des
talismans sur lequel vous êtes si vous
êtes sur un une banque que vous
connaissez ça peut vous rassurer il ya
pas une solution de paiement en ligne et
dans tous les cas on doit vous certifier
et vous prouver que vous êtes sur un
site sécurisé et qu'il n'y a aucun
risque pour vos données bancaires
moi bien souvent ce que je privilégiais
ce que je vais acheter sur internet
cette payer par paypal
ce n'est pas une vidéo sponsorisé par
paypal jeu
aucun lien avec paypal mais paypal c'est
intéressant simplement parce que si vous
avez un problème est bien paypal va
pouvoir gérer les litiges et vous aider
vous accompagner et bien souvent
tranchant en votre faveur je vous donne
un exemple moi ça m'est arrivé il ya
quelques temps j'ai acheté des cartes de
visite je reçois mes cartes de visite
elles sont mal découpé la qualité était
vraiment pas bonne comment ces
entreprises que je connaissais auprès de
laquelle j'avais déjà commandé mais la
banque où j'étais pas du tout satisfait
c'est une entreprise qui était basé en
allemagne
j'ai des contacts et bien évidemment par
leur site web je leur ai envoyé
plusieurs mails disant que j'avais un
problème 2 3 mais je n'ai eu absolument
aucune réponse
j'avais payer par paypal j'ai contacté
paypal chez de vendays paypal géré le
litige j'ai recontacté le e-commerçant
par le biais de paypal j'ai attendu
quelques jours peut-être sept jours sous
7 jours je n'ai pas eu de réponse paypal
a tranché en ma faveur
en disant ok il ya un problème le
e-commerçant t'es pas son travail il
n'assure pas le sav
on va donc vous rembourser le service
comptable du e-commerçant s'est
réveillée peut-être un mois après il m'a
envoyé les mails en menace en me disant
que si je ne payais pas la commande que
j'avais eue si je ne payais pas
l'écarter bien j'allais avoir un
problème
j'étais garantie par paypal j'étais
protégé couverts et les commerçants
pouvaient plus rien faire les à des
cassures et le rsa dès et concerne le
paiement et les choses qui sont vraiment
bien je prends l'exemple d'une banque
sur laquelle je suis que j'utilise
lorsque je pars à l'étranger
serrez vos luttes ils ont un système qui
est pas mal alors je sais pas si ça
existe dans d'autres banques d'ailleurs
si vous le savez marqué le mois en bas
en commentaire le truc qui est vachement
bien en fait c'est que vous pouvez
générer une carte bleue virtuel unique
pour un achat uniquement c'est à dire
que si les coordonnées de votre carte
sont récupérés à la suite de votre achat
et bien c'est complètement inutilisable
pas bien vous piratez ça nous emmène au
cinquième point c'est la gestion des
litiges et ça c'est un truc qui est
extrêmement important pourquoi parce que
lorsque vous achetez bourse est votre
produit jusque là tout est merveilleux
et ensuite il ya un problème avec le
produit
et là ça peut être embêtant si la
personne en face ne vous répond pas ou
ne prend pas au sérieux il ne fait pas
son boulot
des fois c'est un peu compliqué alors il
ya des sites qui sont très sérieux qui
le font merveilleusement bien qu'elle a
d'autres qui sont un petit peu plus
voyez ce que je veux dire alors moyens
ce qui me rassure beaucoup une fois de
plus je ne suis pas payé par ses
amazones parce qu'ils ont un système
pareil de gestion litige qui est
vraiment bien et qui bien souvent va
venir
avantagé le consommateur au détriment du
vendeur le vendeur a vraiment intérêt à
faire son talent derrière s'ils veulent
que ça se passe bien il ya notamment un
service qui s'appelle la garantie de az
qui va mettre avait complètement
remboursé dans la mesure où nous n'avons
pas n'être le produit que propose amazon
c'est bien il ya deux sites ils font
parfaitement bien leur boulot derrière
moi ce que je vous conseille une fois de
plus c'est d'aller vers des sites que
vous avez identifié que vous connaissez
vous savez qu'ils sont sérieux pour
vendre mais également derrière et
justement ça nous emmène au sixième
point
c'est la question du sav le sav ou
service après vente c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est pour moi
un des points les plus importants
acheter un bon prix c'est bien mais si
derrière vous avez aucun interlocuteur
est la personne qui est là pour vous
aider le jour où tu as un problème
eh bien vous êtes carottes je vous
conseille vraiment d'identifier les
sites qui vont pouvoir vous aider sur le
savez comment on peut identifier ça
c'est très simple en règle générale on
identifie très très bien une catégorie
elle savait sur le site sur la catégorie
sav vous devez avoir des coordonnées
pour pouvoir contacter que ce soit un
formulaire que ce soit un email pourquoi
pas un chat c'est encore mieux et si
vous avez un sav par téléphone sa
scénarios montrent au contraire tu es
quelqu'un très très facilement si vous
n'avez pas le numéro de téléphone ça
veut pas dire que le service arrière
n'est pas là et n'existe pas les
vérifier vraiment que vous avez tous les
outils pour faire valoir vos droits
concernant le savez ce que je vous
conseille quand même aussi c'est de
venir jeter un petit coup d'oeil en bas
par les conditions générales de vente et
notamment la politique de retour pour
être sûr pouvoir faire valoir vos droits
facilement et une fois de plus sur tous
les sites de e-commerce français
normalement c'est un week-end plutôt
l'espace septième point c'est la
question des frais lorsque vous
commandez vous arrivez sur le
récapitulatif de votre panier eh bien
vous retrouver avec des frais des fois
un petit peu bizarre ou d'autres frais
qui peuvent apparaître et notamment
lorsque vous commandez à l'étranger
alors je vais pas dire qu'il faut pas
commander à l'étranger
je dis juste vérifier une fois de plus
la note totale ce que vous allez payer
vérifier que le montant de votre panier
correspondent bien aux montants qu'on
vous demande de payer au moment où vous
allez avoir votre paiement carte bleue
et surtout vérifier que vous n'allez pas
avoir des frais qui apparaissent que ce
soit des frais de traitement des frais
de gestion des frais administratifs ou
bien encore des frais préparation
attention également aux coques
extrêmement important ce sont les frais
de transport parce que vous avez le coût
du produit vérifier que c'est bien coût
ttc et non pas un coût hors taxes qu'on
vous met pas le prix du produit qu on
vous rajoute ensuite des taxes etc on
vous rajoute ensuite différents frais
tout de suite où le prix va exploser
attention aux frais de ports bien
souvent notamment sur des marketplace
pour avoir le prix est le plus attractif
un vendeur me proposer un produit moins
cher mais par contre les frais de ports
vont être assez exorbitant est beaucoup
trop chère par rapport à la valeur
d'envoi du produit donc vérifiez bien
regardez bien ce que vous allez payer à
la fin quel est le montant total hors
capes et une lettre type de votre panier
et bien évidemment au moment où vous
allez payer le huitième point
j'ai l'impression d'être passe partout
vous disputer le huitième point c'est le
suivi de votre commande
parce qu'il faut que vous avez commandé
et bien votre produit est en cours de
livraison
vous suivez l'histoire ça sent très
simple vérifier quand même si vous avez
reçu un email de confirmation si vous
pouvez vous connecter vous pour pouvoir
voir où en est votre commande
à quel moment invaincue vivre et voir si
vous avez un sens des clients pour venir
contacter pour avoir plus d'informations
vérifiées vraiment ça parce que si
toutefois il ya un problème je vais
pouvoir annuler en cours de route donc
faut vraiment pouvoir éveiller parce que
si quelqu'un vous vend un produit et
qu'il n'est pas disponible et qu on vous
lit dont je ne sais pas combien de temps
je ne sais pas combien de mois et que
vous n'en avez pas été averties avant
eh bien je pouvais faire valoir notre
droit et pouvoir donner votre commande
donc ça c'est vraiment c'est extrêmement
important
voilà pour ces huit astuces pour vous
aider à acheter dans de bonnes
conditions sur internet j'espère que ça
vous aura aidé l'idée c'est
effectivement ne pas tomber dans la
paranoïa on disons qu'on peut se faire
arnaquer et volaient de partout mais
c'est extrêmement important d'avoir les
bonnes clés dans ce qu'on va acheter
pouvoir identifier le bon vendeur le bon
site pouvoir savoir si cette personne va
capable de répondre à vos besoins et à
vos questions en cas de problème avant
même que vous ayez reçu produits et une
fois que vous l'avez reçu en cas de
problème toute la gestion du sav et j'ai
toutefois y avait un litige avec comment
le régler dans de bonnes conditions
intelligemment pour vous puissiez soit
renvoyer le produit soit recevoir un
autre soit et de soirée pareille
compagnie donc ça c'est extrêmement
important il faut vraiment sécurisé tous
à sécuriser votre paiement que vous
minimiser les risques
lorsque vous allez acheter donner votre
numéro de carte bleue en ligne et donc
tous ces points à prendre en
considération et une fois que vous
mettez en place ça ils sont un peu les
bonnes pratiques d'achats sur internet
vous verrez vous êtes quand même
relativement tranquille j'espère que ça
vous aura aidé j'espère que ça vous aura
intéressés dites moi si vous voulez
comme ça que je donne des tutos des
bonnes astuces des bons plans pour pas
forcément que acheter en ligne
mais pour pouvoir vous aider et vous
accompagnez bien évidemment tout ça en
lien avec la tex vous invite à marquer
tout ça en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve demain pour
continuer à parler des cas les demandes
et bisous puis n'oubliez pas vous
abonner je crois que c'est voilà c'est
juste la clac clac vous cliquiez du joli
poussé compagnie des bisous à demain
ciao
[Musique]